hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Anna okay so I was a big baby
before and I didn't oh okay I got to go
back upstairs I think I don't think
there's anything else down here I got
the bowl but food in the bowl may be
done okay I obviously don't know what
I'm doing with the bowl let me try maybe
filling the flask up it's not really a
puddle it's like a really deep can't use
it fine screw you then all right here we
go
how about you suck on some ashes I don't
want to know okay anyway um so I don't
have a crowbar or a key so that's okay
maybe if I add oh I could add these okay
why did I get this bowl then I'm not
exactly sure I mean I this is water here
this whole upstairs area has gotten
pretty freaky maybe I could put on the
mask of truth no wait oh I didn't I oh
you've got to be kidding me
ah the game crashed oh no just all
tabbed again okay all right we're back
now I don't know it's just all tabbed
again I don't know why but whatever okay
there's this dirty mirror okay
so covered in filth that I can't even
display a reflection scrape it off that
laughs why do I even have the cellphone
do anything with it I don't know I don't
know okay I'm not seeing anything up
here I'm not sure I'm not sure what the
deal is maybe I could pick this pick it
back up cannot get that you can't get
anything looking at me stop it stop it
okay so this says I need something to
live in it live in her up
or give us with the bones where did they
come from no no no I take one last
gander around and then I go back
downstairs maybe I need to start looking
for something to clean off the nevermind
it was nothing if I could start looking
for something to help no no what huh huh
huh huh huh huh huh oh wait no that's
that's shut up oh that's different
that's that that's something else I
don't let me see [ __ ] ha ha no dice I
I don't know what the deal is with this
but aren't you gonna have no idea these
aren't interactable these symbols on the
wall or flames or whatever you want to
call them they're not interactable I
haven't seen much else that is
interactable so I guess we'll go back
downstairs now okay um
don't you worry cuz whenever I get
confused I find something standing
behind me okay so ah man
all the hands are still there okay
what's the deal with this this mask in
the wall blackest night black his death
or as I'd rather define it the leak
can't move it I can't use it so I have
to be able to do something on it maybe
what was the point of that oh wait no
that's what as that's what I was looking
for um other holes within indentations
in them then maybe I could put the mask
of truth in it yeah that might might
might be something oh you stop that now
maybe I could put the mask of truth on
this little hole okay okie dokie weird
house would stop creaking all right boo
behind this table god I'm not alone here
good good good to know drawer was
removed not alone
good to know good no kink that someone
knocked it over
why did you leave no guys not gonna
we're the only one that I could make
snow said it made sense before this
whole thing was on fire okay that must
be like something on the floor I'm
missing
[Music]
mmm freakin what's I mean what's the
deal just hands I really want to know
why hello
okay everyone I know why I did this I
mean seriously what was whoa all right
all right won't move in now for some
reason I'm gonna move it I can't put on
the face of truth face of the truth well
is there something at the beginning of
the now of the note like it was the
saying that the only way to see the
truth or you had to see the truth you
had to like you put blood in the water
maybe
down there nothing here nothing here
there is nothing here nothing at all
nothing at all and go back up again oh
this thing stresses me out there like
you wouldn't believe
okay what's with these oh come on
again again again it alt tabs
okay all right okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay
uh-uh uh-huh no what the hell
all right looks like we crashed the game
so I will be back in just a second and
we're back
okay sorry about that guys don't know
why that happened okay
I actually excuse me that's bullying I
actually don't know what do I I loaded
on my last safe but I obviously haven't
made any progress so I was going
upstairs this gooz to go stairs and I
look around I say hey my buddy hey about
it wait why I came up before why did I
pop up there strange so there is nothing
up here besides this frickin frackin
mirror I don't have anything to clean it
with it my canteen is empty my daughter
does nothing my mobile phone can't clean
anything I have an iron bar a cha crash
brick Damir roar there's gotta be gotta
be something that I miss yes God I mean
why is water just like here fill my
canteen
nope nope I got a canteen Oh shopping
yeah no dice
I know guys iron bar again Oh what does
these come from oh no it's stuck to the
wall
oh boy if I take those shoes and like
put them on the both set up I got there
is that gonna work
okay stuck to the wall how do I get it
unstuck
why have I missed these I swear I've
been coming through everything somehow I
still managed to miss things okay looks
like I'm not gonna be able to get them
off all right okay okay okay all right
these boots are usable there was nothing
else in the wall nothing else on the
floor nothing else anywhere right right
right right right right right right
right right right right right
[Music]
okay so make sure there's nothing on the
wall let me just comb through every room
again really taking a look good look
around there was that thing wait a
minute I remember I'm Susan oh oh oh
stop it I remember nothing there was a
pile of rocks this is the pile of rocks
where was that pile of rush stop it guy
Oh
ah hate this game I hate this game
there's some rocks there were pile of
rocks it said whose pile is rock - the
famous boom outside what was the point
that maybe I could have taken a rock
night
I totally overlooked it cuz I wasn't
thinking clearly I don't know oh you
know where the rocks are anymore no no I
thought they were up here but they may
be not shut got you a loser
you'll lose all what oh yeah oh and it's
so creepy
oh I swore that the rocks were up here
but I suppose I have been wrong before
haha yeah nah-nah-nah-nah
maybe they were downstairs maybe I was
going crazy
ha five all right I don't think I'm
gonna get anywhere if you know this
illusion feel free to write in the
comments I'll be reading so thank you
everybody so much for watching I know
this may or may not be short I don't
know with y'all crushing the game thing
but thank you all so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
part bye-bye